hello everybody and welcome to let's
play nightmare house 2 now this is a
very popular game
we buy a lot of people so I'm going to
assume that it's a popular half-life 2
mod a lot of you wanted me to play it
and I know I said that I was going to do
exclusively horror game but I'm going to
do enough to some other games at the
same time so try let's see if it's
really as scary as some people flavor in
seven chapters ah nothing nothing
I bet it's nothing nothing compared to
what I know and what I've been through
yeah let's see let's see how it really
is loading oh I forgot something I
forgot to turn down the sound sorry guys
sorry sorry about that I'll get it in
just a second audio get get down on you
get down
alright there we go alright hen Missoula
tsuki after finishing the prologue okay
alright I'm guessing the prologue
explains some of the events that happen
- goodnight
if not then okay
they bit me
right flashlights or something
can't go that way
maybe I turned the game down volume down
too much cuz now I can't hear the thing
this is my headphones I'm so stupid I
what's in here at all no nope no one all
right not in love with that head bobbing
but whatever
I guess that's to make it more immersive
leather we got here
why don't we got you're off padlock on
nothing
we're like a whole lot of nothing let's
see I got a hand can't interact with
stuff alright okay
use use ok I forgot I'm so used to
frictional games stuff penumbra anime
amnesia that forget the use button
exists all right
that's some
can't go in the front door this is side
here
tombstone always a good sign
always alright that's nothing
um okay well it wouldn't be a markiplier
let's play if I didn't get lost in the
beginning let me see if I can bash
through this window cuz it's not normal
to you people would do boom nope
banging nope let's see lost I am lost
man come here boop boop nope nothing
um wow I am failing hardcore already wow
this even possible I'm totally not doing
this intentionally Oh lemon come in I
want to be scared come in ah okay
alright maybe there's something I need
to look for um a bunch of garbage blood
going into the house was open no
flashlights let me go back to that shed
thing
maybe there was something in there that
I missed oh I see a light you see a
light oh come on
Oh maybe if I use use the door forgot it
oh yeah there we go oh oh hello
ha that's all you got that's not enough
to scare me who annexed yay all right
this is boom back boom ah bang you back
here BAM boom boom Oh dawn I like this
game already because it guess who gives
me a weapon
oh nothing does stand in my way while I
got my axe
Oh guess who's home Oh better thanks
thanks thanks
come on thanks Fang oh come here
here's Johnny Oh what the f Oh want some
oh who wants some Oh bring I'll bring it
on bring it
hardcore on you there oh now I have a
flashlight
get out of here Oh electricity
ordinarily I'd run straight through that
because I'm so tough but I can't account
for this guy's toughness whoever he is
all right
nothing Oh a fight use a box
oh no don't break box geez hey ah
well alright then maybe it's nothing
maybe it's nothing
oh yeah nothing nothing at all
oh thank you I have a flashlight that
battery doesn't run out oh man thank you
thank you so much well bang bang all
right what do we got
nothing on nothing at all
oh look at my package ha I'm tired of
stairs falling oh gone alright but I
like my ass better oh man this house is
rapid why am I even going in it I don't
even know I don't even know all right me
off to the side damn it darn oh these
are invincible so I can stack oh I'm so
smart so smart
give it up boom come Oh f-you
after you into a aah I'm gonna oh there
we go
whoop nope fail
Oh what the hell my health just tanked
what did I do
that's not the right way obviously
alright
now playing this on hardmode 23 health
good idea
maybe another box what ever get me up
there
oh god aah oh no kill you
oh man angry sure oh yeah got it
Oh who are you ah nobody nobody you
crapped your pants so hard your torso
exploded on that's what happened I say
bloody go oh yeah oh what the [ __ ]
hell
Oh get out of here oh I've been no
health I have no help I smacked you like
a bajillion times
what was that beep I'm not in an HEV
suit yeah your pick whoop that cabinet
off the walls
okay I'm gonna dock
what died of our P my piss lab the next
monster oh thank goodness
oh that wasn't much at all screw you if
you're gonna help help a lot hey hey hey
nope
alright look get away no I said get away
your mother okay that doors oh so many
things are broken in this house
honest-to-goodness this would never pass
inspection I think my flashlight does
run out
oh so angry already I'm angry sorry guys
I don't mean to be a what Oh what
No oh no no I said no I said no there we
go
okay oh I do have a flashlight okay let
it go oh there we go wow what some oh
who wants some oh you're all you're
gonna get it Oh what the [ __ ]
hi hi oh no oh
what do you are ugly Oh ugly ugly ugly
I'll get away
Oh get away oh nice job changing that
face model on that zombie huh huh huh
huh hey what oh ah get out of here
get out of here oh hey no one that's
right run away that's what I thought
well they're a bunch of pansies or
bullets Oh bring it on I don't even eat
bullets I don't even need them yeah I
still have 23 health see there we go all
right Oh bring it on another brick
another broken floor Oh Oh another one
I thought my game was crashing and never
happens all right down to the basement
again I'll go to meet a monster again my
bet just guessing
what's down aah no mother
Oh a chief double hockey sticks Bologna
all right hey I'm gonna save here cut
the video but I will see you guys in the
next part thank you so much for watching
and this has been let's play nightmare
house - bye-bye